le réseau d'hydro-québec se métamorphose
à l'avenir il sera plus décentralisée et
donnera une plus grande place aux
énergies solaire et éolienne dans les
années 60 la construction des grands
barrages fait rêver les québécois il
faut au peuple du québec qui appartient
au peuple du québec sont plus riche
patrimoine celui l'électricité
c'est maintenant ou jamais on y seront
maîtres chez nous aujourd'hui le réseau
électrique est en pleine transformation
navette a vu par images satellites et
vos ressemblé beaucoup à ce qu'on en a
aujourd'hui des grands barrages des
milliers de kilomètres de files qui
transportent l'électricité de la baie
james et du complexe manicouagan
jusqu'au sud de la province
[Musique]
par contre sur le terrain il va tromper
en charge comme à lac-mégantic en estrie
depuis quelques semaines ça bouge en
ville
sept ans après la tragédie détruit par
un convoi chargé de pétrole le centre
ville est en reconstruction
hydro québec avec les gens de la
communauté de lac mégantic avec les élus
ont décidé de déployer au centre ville
de lac-mégantic toutes les composantes
du réseau électrique de la venue ici et
là dans la province des projets
transports ma vision du réseau
électrique
tous se retrouvent pour suivre le
téléroman il y à un monde de différence
entre l'époque de la construction des
barrages et aujourd'hui autrefois on
consommait à la maison ou d'un commerce
des sessions puis en centrale on se
donnait les moyens généraux et lectrices
tic allait servir ce besoin
c'était très humide sélection des
barrages au nord des consommateurs au
sud
aujourd'hui une foison d'équipement font
leur arrivée panneaux solaires éoliennes
batterie voitures électriques
à présent tous peuvent produire stocker
de l'énergie et même alimenter le réseau
l'énergie circule dans une nouvelle
direction
le réseau se décentralise est ce ça
change comble même le comportement du
système électrique tel qu'on l'avait
conçu alors que cette adaptation lol et
l'intégration des ressources des centres
et les éligibles
c'est ça le défi qui s'en viennent en
même temps s'amorce la transition
énergétique
on a des jeux
l'électricité partout et les vieilles
installations sont saufs financer ça ne
coûte pas cher à produire cette masse là
mais si on veut électrifier québec ça va
prendre plus d'énergie en ce moment en
hiver au plus fort de la consommation
nous avons besoin d'une puissance
d'environ 38 mille mégawatts dont plus
de 3900 doivent être achetés en 2029
hydro québec prévoit qu'il faudra près
de 46 mégawatts avec un manque à gagner
d'environ 2 manach c'est économiquement
ça va coûter beaucoup moins cher dans
les années qui viennent de faire de
l'éolien du solaire que probablement
plusieurs de nos grands projets
hydroélectriques dans le futur c'est que
moins cher d'aller chercher de l'énergie
solaire éolien ce soit peut être le
choix confort à la prairie hydro québec
construit sa première centrale solaire
trente mille panneaux sur l'équivalent
de 28 terrains de football
une autre centrale à varennes avoisine
le centre de recherche d'hydro-québec
ensemble ces centrales fourniront 9,5
mégawatts
assez pour alimenter mille résidences au
petit comme ça mais l'intention c'est
pas d'avoir la grosse production c'est
de comprendre ici on va tester une foule
de technologies solaires dont des
panneaux bifaces qui peuvent capter la
lumière par les deux faces et des
panneaux pivotants qui suivent le soleil
quand on parle d'un projet solaire on va
l'enviro 3 en deux temps tic entre
l'expression du besoin et puis la
réalisation du mit ce projet indique un
projet à hydroélectriques environ 12 à
15 le solaire permet de produire
localement
parallèlement une autre révolution
s'opère
elle permet de stocker localement les
batteries de moins en moins cher de plus
en plus performantes
[Musique]
si les veines est ingénieur principal du
groupe de stockage d'énergie aujourd'hui
on teste une par une les batteries qui
sont sur le point d'être installé à la
centrale solaire de la prairie ces
batteries lithium fer phosphate sont
développé et breveté par hydro québec
particulièrement stable et sécuritaire
elles servent au stockage stationnaire
d'immenses quantités d'énergie elles
sont essentielles aux centrales
d'énergie renouvelable renouvelables
mais intermittente
quand un nuage passe au dessus du parc
solaire
la production électrique peut passer de
ça pour ça elle 10 ou 15 pour ça en
quelques secondes
saab des gros impact sur le réseau
électrique le rôle des batteries
stabiliser le réseau
elle se recharge en heures
d'ensoleillement et et que la production
solaire varient elles alimentent le
réseau instantanément mais les batteries
permettent à changement encore plus
important depuis que les réseaux
électriques existants
il était impossible de stocker
l'électricité dans un réseau c'est à
dire qu'en tout temps les centrales
électriques devait produit exactement la
même quantité d'électricité que ce qui
était consommé par les clients
les batteries c'est un élément qui
change complètement la manière dont on
construit dont on opep dont on exploite
le réseau web
[Musique]
à hemmingford en estrie sans fanfare
hydro québec installé ici en 2017 ses
premières batteries à grande capacité
elles sont dans ces immenses compte
d'honneur c'est parce que le poste
électrique qui alimentait la région
était un peu en surcharge pas tout le
temps aux heures de pointe en hiver le
matin le soir alors des douches du
chauffage du grille pain
le système de stockage ce qui fait ce
qui vient en magazines et l'énergie dans
les périodes hors pointe pour permettre
dans les périodes de points de décharger
la batterie et de livres ou clips un
changement radical avec l'approché
vituel ajouter des lignes grossir les
équipes en tout le long du réseau des
années de travail la pointe hivernale
ça ça coûte très cher servir le moment
où on consomme le plus de puissance au
québec ça coûte très cher si on pouvait
baisser cette puissance nécessaire à ce
moment là on sauverait des millions de
dollars la première similaire à celui
des ming freud c'est ce qu'on appelle
une centrale de stockage d'énergie on y
retrouve les batteries mais aussi un
système de télécommunication ultra
performant et des processeurs et surtout
des logiciels une intelligente on a
développé un logiciel qu'on appelle le
système de gestion de l'énergie qui est
le chef d'orchestre qui vient coordonner
tous les morceaux ensemble de manière à
faire en sorte que la centrale de
stockage livre le service dont on a
besoin
ces logiciels marque un tournant la
décentralisation de l'intelligence du
réseau alors on a même de l'intelligence
un peu partout on a des décisions
d'opérations s'appelle localement sans
être humain intervient à lac-mégantic un
projet pilote pousse la décentralisation
plus loin encore le micro réseau un
réseau capable de se débrancher du
réseau d'hydro-québec
on a tout testé les six bons séparément
ailleurs puis à lac-mégantic on met tout
un ensemble puis la faute ou marchent
ensemble en même temps voici le micro
réseau de lac-mégantic un périmètre
défini comprenant bâtiments résidentiels
et commerciaux
on y retrouve des batteries des panneaux
solaires une panoplie de technologies
nouvelles de fabricants d'hiver qui
doivent collaborer en temps réel un
casse tête pour les ingénieurs
cette grappe d'instruments se raccorde
au réseau un point précis le voici sur
la carte et sur le terrain il est sûre
ce poteau frédéric durand nous a servi
de guide
il connaît les secrets de la
reconstruction plaque mégantic et ses
moindres fils le micro réseau pour être
autonome plusieurs heures par jour
davantage en été et fonctionner même en
cas de panne du grand réseau
une première au québec on va se servir
soi de la production des cellules
photovoltaïques soit de l'énergie
stockée dans les piles pour alimenter
toutes les bâtiments qui sont raccordés
dans notre micro réseau pendant cette
période là notre besoin des barrages on
a tous besoin de l'énergie le clip qui
vient d'ailleurs
[Musique]
caché derrière le centre sportif voici
le cerveau du micro réseau
ça c'est une nouveauté d'avoir un
équipement externe au réseau qui a
lui-même passé une commande sur un
équipement du réseau pour dire je me
synchronise où je me dis synchronise eu
raison
à lac mégantic cette décentralisation va
encore plus loin dans plusieurs
bâtiments on retrouve des batteries et
des panneaux solaires individuels ils
sont contrôlés à même les édifices par
des logiciels une intelligence
hyperlocal pour encore mieux gérer les
périodes de pointe
bref c'est édifice est en constante
communication avec le cerveau du
micro-réseau à 300 mètres de là haut ce
que le contrôle du micro réseau va dire
à dire aux autres board mardi bagdad
consommation essayer de prendre un peu
moins d'énergie pour que je sois capable
de passer ma points ou utilisent
l'énergie des batteries
[Musique]
ces logiciels locaux pourraient même
contrôler les chauffe-eau ou tirer
profit des batteries des voitures
électriques de nouvelles ressources
mises en commun qui permettrait
d'optimiser la consommation électrique
de quartier et de ville et ultimement
fera baisser le coût global de la
production d'électricité
les grandes centrales on va en avoir
encore besoin pour toujours autant pour
fournir l'énergie que pour équilibrer
fournée la puissance en arrière garde et
la fiabilité globale du gosse
dans les laboratoires d'hydro-québec on
veut modéliser des futurs possibles un
réseau avec une foule de batteries des
centrales solaires des dizaines de
micros raison tout ça pour faire les
meilleurs choix pour chaque région selon
leurs contraintes et leurs besoins
[Musique]
à lac mégantic pour la première fois la
population ne consommera certain moment
que de l'énergie produite localement
chez eux
la résilience c'est vraiment je pense
d'un mot clé maintenant pour s'assurer
qu'on doit cette autonomie cette
capacité de nous retourner dans
n'importe quelle situation n'importe
quel événement qui vient chambouler les
choses et c'est un mouvement de fond qui
apparaît dans les systèmes électriques
un peu partout et on peut pas faire fi
ça va être long
[Musique]
dans les années 60 le réseau
d'hydro-québec a été un projet de
société le futur pour être fait de
projets à l'échelle des communautés
donnant un nouveau sens à l'expression
être maîtres chez nous
[Musique]
oh